now that you've learned all the chords
that go in the key of c you should learn
a song which uses those chords so this
is one of my favorites it's let her go
by passenger in the key of c plus your
capo at the fourth fret
well you only need the light when it's
burning low
only miss the sun when it starts to snow
only know you love her when you let her
go
only know you've been high when you feel
low
only hate the road when you're missing
home
only know your lover when you let her go
and you let her go
staring at the bottom of your class
hoping one day you'll make your dream
last and dreams come slow and they go so
fast
you see it when you close your eyes
when it starts to snow
only know you love her when you let it
go
only know you can die when you feel low
staring at the ceiling in the dark same
old empty feeling in your heart his love
goes slow and it goes so fast
when you see you when you fall asleep
but never to touch it never to keep
cause you're laughing too much
only know you love her when you let it
go
only know you love him when you let her
go
will you let it go
cause you only need the
only know you've been high and you feel
only miss the sun when it starts to snow
only know you love it when you let it go
only know you've been high when you feel
low
only hate the road when you're missing
home
only know you love her when you let it
go
and you let her go